dur fin de campagne pour Simone Veil
hier soir elle n'a guère plus parler de
l'Europe les deux réunions débats
qu'elle devait tenir à Paris ont en
effet été perturbé par des commandos
d'extrême droite du Front national de
Jean-Marie Le Pen Jean-Marie Le Pen qui
était là en personne rue le pic ou les
incidents ont été les plus violents
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après tout a dégénéré la bagarre est
devenue générale les chaises et les
points ont volé bas les militants des
Front national ce sont déchaînés en tout
cas madame Fay hier soir a dû partir en
catimini et la troisième réunion qu'elle
devait tenir dans le 20e arrondissement
a été annulé